امام نافذه مكتب الصرافه ينتظرنا بترقب
وصول حوالات ماليه مشهد سيبدو مالوفا لو
كان خارج اسوار هذا المكان لكن هن زوجات
مقاتلي داعش وهذا مكتب صرافه داخل مخيم
روج الذي ياوي عائله التنظيم وجلهم من
الاجانب
تسمح قوى الامن في المخيم التابعه لاداره
الذاتيه شمال سوريا لمكاتب الصرافه بالعمل
داخل مخيمات الدواعش تحت رقبتها لصالح
مبالغ ماليه المقيمين هنا والذين يقولون
انها من اقاربهم
لمساعدتهم على تكاليف الحياه
[موسيقى]
يمكن لكل عائله داخل المخيم تسلم ما بين
دولار امريكي شهريا رسميا يقول القائمون
على المخيمات ان الاموال ترسل من ادلب
التي تسيطر عليها فصائل مواليه لتركيا او
من داخل تركيا نفسها
المصادر الاموال كلياتهم من اهاليون
اهاليون موجودين بادلب اغلبيتهم كلياتهم
ومن تركيا ويلي خارج
نطاق دوله تركيا او من اتلف كمان بعض
الاهالي منهم بيبعتوا على تركيا من تركيا
بيبعثوهم
من تركيا على ادلب ومن ادلب كمان لماذا
تركيا كليه ما بعرف يعني هي اساس المقر هي
بترميها
السماح بوصول الاموال العائله التنظيم
يبرره المسؤولون هنا باسباب انسانيه
فمساعده المنظمات الاغاثيه غير كافيه للسد
احتياجات العائلات اليوميه لكن الخطير عدم
قدره احد على تحديد او تتبع مصادر التمويل
تضمن ان نعيش
مثلا في طريقه داعش تقدر تحوليه من مناطق
اللي تحت سيطره نصر جبهه وداعش وهيكل
وجميع عمله واحده يعني
ما فيك بس
نجحت نساء التنظيف في مخيمات شمال سوريا
مره كثيره على مدار السنوات الماضيه في
جمع الاموال عبر حملات تبرعات باسماء
مشفره في منصات ماليه كما يحصلن على
مساعدات ماليه من متعاطفين مع داعش
والغطاء الابرز عائله
بعض التحقيق والدراسه عن هالوضع
الاغلبيه لانه في بعض التواصلات عن طريق
الهواتف
وبشكل علني انه نبعت هالمسار للاخوات
الموجودين اللي يقاومون ضمن المخيم حتى
يقوم بتربيه اولادهم بشكل افضل
عن طريق الهواتف يجون توجيهات يعني هل
اموال كيف يتصرفوا فيها
اما الغايه فتمويل محاولات هروبهن او شراء
اسلحه او حتى شراء ولاءات النازحين
واللاجئين داخل المخيمات معلومات اوصلت
الاداره الذاتيه للتحالف الدولي ضد داعش
ودول غربيه
فقط يتطلب عمل مستمر لانه يعني بلكي بعض
البنوك تم كشف عنهم بيحاولون يغيرون
بنوك اخرى او لمصادر اخرى
مصادر من داخل مخيم الهول رفضت الافصاحه
عن هويتها كشفت ان خلايا داعش هددت عمال
اغاثه محليين يعملون مع منظمات دوليه اما
للحصول على اموال منهم او لاجبارهم على
مساعدتهم في تهريب اشخاص من داخل المخيم
فالتمويل والترهيب وفكر التنظيم المتشدد
ادوات يحافظ عليها استمرار بقائه وان كان
ذلك في المخيمات او السجون صار بن عيشوبه
العربيه
من شمال شرق سوريا